pride we laughed we tréminis to have a
lot of soda hey mal and Evie you've
taught us a lot about friendship since
the first Descendants movie we know that
sometimes friends are more like our
family because of you too and we just
love knowing that you will always be
besties it's awesome that you are
totally friends in real life too that
just makes watching The Descendants
movies that much better dove Cameron and
Sophia Carson aren't the only Disney
Channel co-stars who are BFFs it's
really common for Disney stars to form
lasting friendships with their cast
mates keep watching to see the real-life
friendships of 10 Disney favorites you
guys are really close yeah
Bella Thorne and zendaya Bella Thorne
and Scindia both got their fame from
Disney Channel's shake it up
they played backup dancers trying to
become famous but these two didn't start
out as friends Disney Channel pushed
them to be rivals they were forced to
compete with each other when all they
wanted was to be friends the first
season was really awkward but then the
two had a long heart-to-heart they cried
and talked about how they were feeling
from that moment on they were best
friends shake it up may have ended in
2013 but Bella and Zendaya's friendship
is still going strong
Bella quotes India in her new book about
always being the CC to her Rakhi Bella
says the feeling is mutual Bella has
also recently been in a huge scandal and
zendaya reached out to make sure she was
okay she told Bella that she is strong
and beautiful and Bella acknowledged
that all a girl needs is the support of
her friends and she can handle anything
we love that these two are still showing
us what a fierce friendship is all about
they've overcome a lot and they always
have each other's backs Peyton Elizabeth
Li and Joshua Rush when we think of best
friends forever
we definitely think of the squad from
Andy Mack Andy is too amazing BFFs Cyrus
and Buffy none of them are perfect but
they all accept each other for who they
are and they all mature a lot together
too it turns out that their ethic
friendship isn't fake
Josh a secret he would definitely tell
you they are all great friends from your
life to Peyton Elizabeth Lee and Joshua
rush are really close you guys are
really close yeah
they always look like they are having
the best times together and they aren't
afraid to show the world just how much
they love each other
Peyton posted an amazing
behind-the-scenes photo on the last
night of Andy Mack
she said she would always remember that
night Josh came in and commented that he
loved her it's always great when best
friends can show their love they are
always being goofy and Sophia Wiley and
Asher angel are usually goofing off with
them too there's no way they can fake
being that good of friends we hope that
they continue to be besties even though
Andy Mack is over Peyton lists and Skye
Jackson Peyton list and Skye Jackson
have start together on not one but two
Disney Channel shows they were on Jessie
and on the spin-off show bumped Peyton
may play the older sister but these two
are only about four years apart and it
is clear from their social media that
they're super close our sister pallet
Skye who played Zuri Ross on the show
often shows up in Peyton's snapchat
stories the two love to post selfies
together just like any two BFFs they did
the cinnamon challenge together which is
a serious bonding moment we definitely
wouldn't eat a whole spoon of cinnamon
with someone we weren't comfortable with
and they slayed the red carpet together
with their on-screen brother the late
great Cameron voice back in 2017 we love
the big sister little sister friendship
that these two have we hope that they
reunite on-screen and off-screen in the
future Raven Symone and annalisa
Vanderpool if you ask kids of the early
2000s who their friendship icons were
they might say Raven and Chelsea these
two Disney Channel BFFs were the stars
of that So Raven Raven played the
psychic teen who was smart but was
always getting into trouble Chelsea was
her loyal bestie who wasn't always super
quick
now these two are back has divorced moms
on Ravens home but did you know that
Raven Symone and annalisa van der pol
are real-life friends they became
amazing friends back when they were on
That's So Raven his teens it's why they
were eager to reunite for the new show
annalisa calls them a unit that no one
can break they dealt with major teen
issues together both on the show and off
and their friendship is even stronger
because of it we hope that we can stay
close to our besties forever just like
Raven and annalisa dove Cameron and
Sophia Carson now that descendants 3 is
taking over the Disney Channel community
we can't talk about Disney besties
without mentioning mal and Evie these
two might be the closest to on-screen
friends Disney has ever shown they found
comfort in each other when their parents
couldn't offer them any they'd lift each
other up and always have each other's
backs dove Cameron and Sophia Carson are
the same way these two friends are super
close they are always posting selfies
together and they always post the cutest
birthday messages on each other's social
media platforms when descendants three
wrapped dove said she and Sophia just
laid on a bridge on set they held hands
and reminisced until the crew kicked
them out then they ate junk food and
cried with the rest of the cast they are
seriously BFF goals we hope to see a lot
more of these two besties in the future
which Disney star would you want to be
BFFs with and why tell us in the
comments thanks for watching give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe we'll see you next time on
the things
[Music]